deep in the magical snowy landscapes of
Finnish Lapland near the glistening city
of Rovaniemi is the place this Santa
calls home visitors from all over the
world make the pilgrimage to Santa Claus
village up in the Arctic Circle every
year since 1985 Santa has welcomed
thousands of guests young and old right
here in his own living room he listens
to all their wishes
hello I am Santa Claus and I feel I'm
quite real we are right now here at the
Arctic Circle which is Gateway to the
north but it's also gateway to the world
of fairy tales and dreams and wonderful
place to make a wish this is one place
where no one doubts the existence of
Santa Claus I don't think you're ever
too old to believe in Santa Claus since
my childhood I know there is a guy who
can give so I just want to see now
whether he is real or not so that's why
I came here Santa Claus actually could
speak Portuguese yes yes I think he is
polyglot or something like this and
every year about 500,000 letters and
cards with wish lists arrived at his
official post office of course father
Christmas can't answer that many letters
himself but he has a host of busy elves
who lend a helping hand
we are open all year round every day and
this is like a normal post of his here
in Finland you can send your cards
parcels you can place nice stamps and of
course this is the place where all this
letters to the Santa Claus comes to what
people and children are writing visitors
like to send postcards stamped with an
Arctic Circle postmark to their friends
and families Santa Claus gives every
letter his full attention but some are
more memorable than others
sometimes I cut the letters in which
little boys or girls tell that they have
everything they need but they know
somebody who is in who is in need and
they ask me to remember them and they
this kind of letters are very clear to
my hearts the whole theme park based on
Christmas in Santa Claus village
visitors can experience the entire
spectrum of the Christmas season every
day for lovers of Christmas the village
near Rovaniemi has been the place to get
into the spirit for 30 years now but
legend has it that Santa's real home is
much farther north
we were always told that Santa is from
Kaurava to Natori that is a mountain
called air mountain because Santa could
hear all the wishes of the kids around
the world but it lies in a very remote
area very close to finding a Russian
border and it's hard to get in there
that's why basically Santa's Village was
built for the travelers to meet Santa in
a more easy way Santa Claus village is
open all year round but it fills most
genuine in the winter months when the
temperature drops to minus 20 degrees
Celsius perfect for a little jaunt with
a dogsled reindeer pulled sleighs and a
more stately pace so how does Santa
managed to deliver so many gifts to so
many children
time is relative and that's it you just
have to know how to be in the millions
of different places around the same time
and after practicing it so well a couple
of centuries I think I managed it's
quite well the atmosphere gets really
cozy in the evening with glowing
campfires and entertaining music shows
even the most stubborn Scrooge succumbs
to the holidays enchantment and for
those who aren't fortunate enough to
visit him Santa has this message I wish
you all a very very happy Christmas